la phase actuelle du procès est dite du
fond c'est à dire que des enquêteurs de
la brigade criminelle ou de la section
anti-terroriste présente des éléments
l'objectif est d'établir des liens des
complicités entre les accusés qui se
trouve dans le box et les terroristes
évidemment des accusés qui nie
farouchement cette complicité bien sûr
association de malfaiteurs et complicité
de terrorisme et bien les peines
encourues ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
et pendant ce temps là les victimes et
les parties civiles attendent des
réponses
alors quels sont les éléments justement
nous allons voir cela avec franck
serfaty qui est avocat et président de
l'association vigilance président de la
cour d'assises spéciale a commencé de
façon chronologique elle tout d'abord
l'audition des journalistes et de la
sphère de charlie hebdo puis on a eu un
bon rouge puis les victimes de lithaire
cacher à la porte de vincennes paris 20e
effectivement depuis quelques jours
maintenant nous sommes à une étape plus
de technique puisque circulent défilent
à la barre défilent à la barre des
techniciens les enquêteurs les
directeurs de l'enquète qui viennent
apporter des précisions sur les fadettes
leurs repérages téléphoniques
les gardes à vue des accusés leur
audition donc on est sur une phase
relatives à l' enquête de police qui
effectivement être un peu plus technique
où l'on découvre les liens les liens
entre les accusés via tout d'abord des
réseaux et des appels téléphoniques
récurrents précis puisqu'il y avait bien
évidemment une connexité à tout le moins
personnelle entre les différents accusés
et nous abondons donc effectivement
cette phase de l' enquête policière avec
effectivement encore une fois tout ce
qui est le repérage suivi téléphonique
ainsi que les gardes à vue alors on
regrette tout de même que ces relevés
qui doivent permettre de situer des
déplacements ne soient pas présentés sur
des cartes ce n'est pas très lisible
une avocate nous a confié que dans le
dossier ils apparaissent comme des
relevés excellent sur des dizaines de
pages cela n'aide pas du tout à la
compréhension alors que des moyens
techniques simples permettraient de
l'est figuré et puis il faut dire
qu'aujourd'hui au programme on a évoqué
le trafic d'armes entre lille et
harry ces hommes qui ont servi aux
terroristes auraient été acheminés par
des accusés qui se trouve dans le box
est un des hommes clés de ce trafic
s'appelle claude hermant c'est un indic
également mais il n'est pas au rang des
accusés il figure dans le procès en tant
que témoin les avocats de la défense
certains en tout cas s'en indigne je
vous propose d'écouter ce propos
isabelle coutant-peyre l'avocate du
principal accusé
je voudrais rappeler que quand on a dit
que c'est la défense qui a fait citer le
seul fait établi un dossier à savoir que
les armes ont été vendues par un
monsieur herman quai des milieux
d'extrême droite du nord de la france un
indicateur et de la gendarmerie et de la
police et des douanes ne sont pas
poursuivis c'est moi qui ai demandé leur
citation à comparaître aux audiences et
j'ai demandé avant l'autre l'ouverture
des débats à ce qu' il ya une vrai dire
un complément d'information pour les
poursuivre parce que c'est le seul fait
établi
on pourra vous raconter n'importe quoi
vous dire quatre ans d'instruction très
sérieux on n'a pas poursuivi les gens
qui sont officiellement les fournisseurs
non il faut tout de même préciser que
les avocats des parties civiles dans
leur majorité ne sont pas de cet avis et
estime que l'instruction a été bien mené
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
journée très technique qui permet
d'établir des liens entre les accusés du
box et les terroristes